le féminisme est une question d'égalité et c'est
une question de choix
[Musique]
J'ai commencé à remettre en question les hypothèses fondées sur le sexe il y
a longtemps, quand
j'avais huit ans, j'étais confus d'être appelé autoritaire
parce que je voulais diriger les pièces
que nous monterions pour nos parents
plus j'ai auditionné, plus je
voulais avoir la pause, je veux dire que je voulais avoir
le rôle depuis le début, je l'ai pris au
sérieux
aussi pathétique que cela puisse paraître et vous
savez comme un million contre un vous savez qu'un
million de filles voulaient jouer Hermione
[  Musique]
[Musique] le
féminisme par définition est la conviction
que les hommes et les femmes devraient avoir des
droits et des opportunités égaux et je pense qu'il
est juste que je sois payée de la même manière que mes
homologues masculins Je pense qu'il est juste
que je sois capable de prendre des décisions
à propos de mon propre corps, je pense
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [Musique]
Et si, comme c'est le cas dans beaucoup trop d'
universités, on nous transmet le message
que la violence sexuelle n'est pas vraiment une
forme de violence
[Musique]
mon grand  la passion dans tout  cela a été
de s'assurer que c'est le
mouvement mondial, il s'agit de femmes debout
côte à côte, femmes et hommes,
sur tous les lieux de travail, car nous savons
que cela se produit partout
[Musique]